seguramente me metí en un muy gran
problema al tratar de ponerle fórmulas
números algo medible a un fenómeno como
es generar la felicidad
y más siendo yo médico y viniendo a una
universidad creo que va a ser muy
difícil y tendré que auxiliar me de las
muy altas matemáticas que aprendí entre
el 1º y 3º de primaria para poder
explicar esta fórmula
vamos pensando si juanito tiene 5
manzanas
regala una jose
una susana y una jesús que le queda
seguramente ya respondieron que les
quedan dos manzanas
y si así lo respondieron su maestra les
dijo que estaba bien la respuesta y les
puso una estrella
hoy después de algunos años de haber
pasado por esas aulas de primaria
creo que puede no ser la única respuesta
a ese problema
porque restar
porque restar si lo primero que nos
enseñaron siempre fue a contar de manera
ascendente y progresiva y era un gran
logro cuando lograba llegar hasta 100 y
tenías que llegar cada vez a más y
entonces nos enseñaron la suma de dos de
tres de cuatro cifras y cada vez
teníamos que sumar cifras más grandes
para obtener resultados más grandes
mientras más rápido obtuviera resultados
más grandes eras un genio
después las manzanas se cambiaron por
pesos por qué no por dólares para
enseñar la conversión fuera del aula las
manzanas se cambiaron por cuentas de
banco casas departamentos empresas y
seguramente cumplen muy bien la función
mientras más acumulas mejor eres
mientras más tienes mientras más eres
mientras más te reconocen más felices
y es que nos han vendido que la
felicidad se obtiene de tener más de ser
más o de lograr más
todos queremos ser felices no hay una
sola persona en la faz de la tierra que
no quiera ser o estar feliz la felicidad
es el bien más anhelado por la humanidad
lo busca el rico lo busca el pobre lo
busca el buen o lo busca el malo aunque
quizás no por los mejores caminos no
busca el joven lo busca el anciano el
varón o la mujer
es lo que todos buscamos no es una meta
no es algo permanente es más no es algo
que puedas poseer
es algo tan etéreo tan efímero que
aunque hoy te sientas inmensamente feliz
nos acaban de decir lo constante es el
cambio y esa felicidad puede
desvanecerse claro esto nos da la
oportunidad de volver a generarla y el
problema en nuestro planeta es que por
este
idea de siempre acumular más para ser
más felices estamos a punto de
extinguirlo
hoy hemos escuchado muchas cosas de
felicidad
qué tiene esto que ver con las restas
pues creo que hasta el momento nada
pero bueno todavía tengo unos minutos de
la charla para tratar de hacerlos
entender porque creo que restar siempre
multiplica en la fórmula de la felicidad
hace algunos meses al final de un
extenuante y muy emocionante día de
consulta en el hospital civil donde
incluso celebramos el final del
tratamiento de un niño es el momento más
feliz deseado desde que se hace el
diagnóstico durante dos años y medio
casi tres por el niño por la familia por
todos los que lo aman por todos los que
estamos involucrados e incluso también
por los que están sentados en la sala de
espera viendo esa celebración cuando
ellos están empezando el camino les da
una luz de esperanza
había sido un día muy extenuante llamé
al último paciente y observé que del
elevador salieron dos mujeres muy
delgadas muy humildes y cuando me vieron
disfrazado en la puerta hicieron la
expresión de es él y corrieron para
alcanzarme antes de que entrara el
consultorio yo me percaté de esto se
acercaron y me dijeron doctor queremos
hablar con usted
pase al paciente para que los residentes
fueran revisándolo y me dispuse a ver en
qué podía ayudar a esas señoras que
seguramente necesitaban algo de mí
doctor es que yo el otro día lo vi el
sábado en la mañana en un programa en un
programa que lleve muchas veces donde
usted ha salido muchas veces y está
siempre con niños y con casos pidiendo
ayuda para los niños
entonces yo tengo muchas ganas de ayudar
pero no tengo no tengo cómo ayudar no
tengo dinero no sé cómo hacer para
ayudar no tengo tiempo lo volví a ver el
sábado me acordé de usted bueno lo vi
hace muchos sábados y entonces empecé a
decidir qué de los duros que yo vendo en
la calle una moneda y ver para mí una
moneda y bale para ayudar a los niños
con cáncer y hoy hoy hoy decidí venir
gracias a mi compañera yo no sé dónde
está el hospital civil no sé moverme por
este lado de la ciudad pero hoy le
traigo esto inmediatamente de una bolsa
de mano sacó una bolsa de monedas que
pesaba mucho
y me el entrego
me había hablado tan rápido y tan
atropelladamente que ni siquiera me dejó
preguntarle su nombre
cómo se llama usted
teresita
se llama teresita me dijo su compañera
con un brillo en los ojos lágrimas y un
nudo en la garganta como la persona que
está presenciando el acto más sublime de
la humanidad
doctor yo voy a seguir vendiendo duritos
y voy a regresar a ayudar yo sé que
usted va a hacer llegar eso a quien más
lo necesite
la abrace me abrazaron
se abrazaron entre ellas felices y se
fueron platicando entre risas hacia el
elevador y desaparecieron
me quedé congelado
y yo que pensaba que me iban a pedir
algo
cuando lo que les quemaba en el alma era
entregarme
lo que habían restado de sus ganancias
de no sé cuántos días meses de trabajo
y me lo depositaron que gran generosidad
que gran corazón
qué gran responsabilidad tenía en las
manos
hasta se me había olvidado que tenía un
paciente adentro
entré al consultorio metí la bolsa en la
maleta del disfraz firmé la receta del
niño y terminamos el día
me fui a casa llevando esa bolsa en la
maleta para contarlas todas esas monedas
y depositar el donativo a una iniciativa
que teníamos que se llamaba la caja
dorada un tesoro que compraba
medicamentos cuando el hospital no los
tenía
pero que se había agotado
en ese momento entendí que teresita iba
a resucitar esa iniciativa
llegué a casa 916 monedas y un billete
de 20 pesos
2025 pesos con 50 centavos
estoy seguro que teresita necesitaba ese
dinero mucho más que cualquier
iniciativa
ella estaba tan delgada porque seguro no
comía bien y sin embargo los había
depositado en mis manos
meses después faltó un medicamento
indispensable para los niños no solo en
mi hospital en todo el país
hicimos una convocatoria para la caja
dorada y eso es 2025 pesos con 50
centavos se multiplicaron por la
generosidad de muchas personas que
restaron de su bolsillo y pudimos
importar medicamentos para salvar vidas
de niños atendidos en jalisco en chiapas
y en tabasco
ni siquiera sé el apellido de teresita
ni sé en qué rumbo de la ciudad vende
sus gritos para irle a contar como su
generosidad fue la semilla que salvó
vidas en tres estados de la república
desde hace 4 años durante el mes de
enero
hacemos una recolección de trajes de
superhéroes y princesas para vestir a
nuestros niños que están luchando contra
el cáncer de la ilusión y del poder de
las princesas y de los héroes hacerlos
revestirse de un poder cuando se me
ocurrió esto
no imaginé lo que iba a pasar
este fenómeno se convirtió en una
fábrica de felicidad
el desfile al centro de acopio que así
ya elegantemente al consultorio
niños y niñas de todos los estratos
sociales padres de familia abuelitos
abuelas llegan como en peregrinación
casi como si fueran a llevar algo
venerable a un lugar sagrado llevan esos
vestidos restan de su guardarropa
algunos restan de su bolsillo y nos
entregan esos trajes y es impresionante
ver cómo llegan radiantes de felicidad
las niñas llegan cargando su vestido los
accesorios me sientan me cuentan la
historia en qué fiesta de cumpleaños lo
usaron cómo se sintieron quién le compro
los zapatos quién le compro los aretes y
qué feliz fue y que solamente espera que
la niña que se lo ponga sea tan o más
feliz que ella me lo entrega y se va
feliz y esto se empieza a acumular y se
empieza a multiplicar
a tal grado que desaparece la planta
baja de nuestra casa de tantas cajas con
vestidos y necesitamos ayuda y aparecen
voluntarios este año tuvimos 40
voluntarias que le restaron a sus días
horas a sus trabajos y nos regalaron
entre 6 y 8 horas todos los días hábiles
de febrero para aparecer como modistas
como hadas mágicas que iban a ayudarle a
cada niño a cada niña a encontrar ese
traje que le generará un momento de
felicidad inolvidable quizás hasta una
anécdota
yo estoy dando consulta afuera en
guardarropa y hay un movimiento
increíble hay risas niños probándose
quitándose poniéndose voluntarias
buscando que este no me queda que éste
me aprieta de aquí que no tiene uno que
esté más grandecito ay quiero el de
aquella niña también
al final del día me entero hoy regreso
una niña que el año pasado salió un
vestido de 15 años
y ella vino a contarnos que ya había
perdido su fiesta 15 años por estar
enferma que cuando la vieron llegar en
el camión al pueblo con ese vestido
todos los vecinos se organizaron y le
dieron su fiesta perdida
un vestido puso a todo un pueblo generar
felicidad para una chica que había
perdido esa ilusión
qué tantas restas sub o restas de tiempo
restas de dinero restas de vestidos
1815 disfraces trajes juntamos este año
para entregar en cinco estados de la
república hacer felices a más de 1.815
familias
no sé cuántos integrantes por familia
los voluntarios cuando yo les agradecía
que estuvieran esa mañana con nosotros
me abrazaban se toman la foto y me
decían no gracias a usted por darnos
esto
yo solo los puse a trabajar
cuántas personas se pondrían felices no
lo sé los medios me preguntan doctor es
que si usted le pone el traje de
superhéroe cómo suben las defensas del
niño
no suben las defensas del niño
tampoco le duelen menos los piquetes
es más
hay niños
que lo último que usaron antes de la
bata de hospital con la que murieron fue
ese disfraz
no cambio el destino
y entonces por qué hacer esto doctor
porque todos se quedan felices
la felicidad el bien más anhelado por
todos y sin embargo no es estándar hoy
hemos escuchado a doce gigantes
hablarnos de la felicidad de doce
maneras posibles
ninguna idéntica a otra
y sin embargo todos nos hablaron de
felicidad imagínate tú ser capaz de
generar felicidad que necesitas sonreír
ser intenso un cambio una reacción
un esquema de un triángulo un costal una
bala decisión oportunidad servicio amor
ni siquiera todas juntas con un alavés
que uses puedes generar el bien más
preciado por toda la humanidad
juanito
ya se me estaba olvidando juanito y sus
manzanas que le queda a juanito
le quedaron tres nuevos amigos
le quedó un plátano que le dio susana me
dio sandwich que le dio josé tres tragos
del agua de jesús
y dos manzanas
que le dieron la oportunidad de hacer
feliz a don javier que limpia la escuela
y alberto que cuida la puerta
teresita me rompe todos los esquemas de
la pirámide de maslow me la volteo
teniendo ella tantas necesidades resto
de sí misma para multiplicar la
felicidad de otras personas
sin importarle cuánto lo pudiera haber
necesitado ella teresita resto lo básico
para ella
tú
que eres capaz de restar para
multiplicar la felicidad de los demás
[Aplausos]